hi shel hickey how are you
i'm better now that i see you
you're sweet
your movie is incredible i watched it
last night with my kids
it was everything you kind of want a
modern-day cinderella to be and you as
you know the fabulous fairy godmother
was what we all needed it was
magnificent did you love it as much as
we kind of loved it
well here's
just being completely transparent
okay
i haven't seen the movie yet
well you're fabulous
i've seen my part
i've seen my part
but i haven't seen the rest of the movie
i am so excited to see it because from
what i hear from everybody now
you know talking with everybody today it
feels like it's a thing
like i feel like your honesty as a
fabulous fairy godmother is what
everyone needs what would you need from
your fairy godmother like what kind of
energy and what would you want
now the what i what i gave
you know and that was one thing that i
set out to be
you know the fairy godmother for my
younger self
for the little queer boy you know
sitting in the closet trying on my
auntie's high-heeled shoes
you know being bullied every day at
school you know it was like
i
understood in the moment
that my presence in this iconic
role
was for that
for every
little one
and big one
and anybody in between who has ever felt
othered
you know who has ever felt outside of
the margin
you know
that's who i did it for that's who i
created that person for
um well tell you you resonated with my
kids because we watched on here at home
and it was it was level it was so
beautiful thank you
thank you i appreciate that
you know and the things
well sorry go ahead
well one of the things you know one of
the the tagline for me personally has
been
you know we went to
to shoot it this was
january february of 20.
and um you know
there were some grumblings and some
press and you know what is this and what
is it going to be and
you know somebody asked me and i you
know how are you going to do this and i
just say it's like it's magic
it's magical magic has no gender
that's right
gender
we have placed gender on magic
we as flawed humans have placed gender
on everything
take the gender out of the conversation
take the gender out of the conversation
of everything
it's not just about god it's about
everything
i see that through my kids eyes i see
that through my children's eyes because
they don't see that they really
um and it's a beautiful thing so i love
that you did that and camila cavale said
you know we talked to her a couple of
weeks ago and she told us that youtube
really bonded and that you really were
her real fabulous godmother
um what was it like taking her under
your wing
she is
a magical human being to sort of
reiterate
you know it
what i love
about her
is a her talent i keep forgetting to say
her talent but that goes unsaid i mean
that that
doesn't need to be said she's extremely
talented
but what i was so moved by
is a young woman
of her
fame
yes who is so grounded
and present and open and available
and like a sponge
you know and ready not only to
receive
but to also give
you know understanding that the position
that she's in
is
that of a role model
and that she is present enough to
understand
that that's necessary
people need her
and she gets that
yeah
i love that i love the energy between
the both of you i love the energy you
give
um
this role it's just so special um i also
want to say a huge congratulations on
your emmy nominations thank you
what does that feel like
you know
it's
magical once again it's like
all this stuff
happening
to me
finally after all this time
because
i chose myself
because i chose my truth because i chose
the road less traveled when everybody
around me was telling me my queerness
was my liability
would be my liability and it was four
decades until it wasn't
and now i get to show the world
what it looks like take your time
be patient and be
honest and truthful and authentic and
exactly who you are
be that
it's
very powerful
yes well thank goodness for you we love
you as the fabulous
godmother and we want to see more of
this energy you're just you're such a
light and the world needs it so thank
you for taking the time today absolutely
my pleasure